even with all the publicity she's
received since Game of Thrones premiere
there are still plenty of fun facts and
discoveries to be made about the
talented actress Emilia Clarke a
singular talent who still has an
extraordinary future ahead of her here
are just a few of the untold truths
about Clark's life and career
thanks to her starring role in HBO's
massive hit series Game of Thrones
Emilia Clarke has become one of the most
recognizable faces on television beyond
Game of Thrones Clark has appeared in
other high-profile roles - including
star turns and films like solo a Star
Wars story and Terminator Genisys so far
her most significant role has certainly
been Daenerys Targaryen otherwise known
as Khaleesi and the mother of dragons
Game of Thrones is a notoriously fleshy
adventure series and Emilia Clarke
racked up quite a few nude scenes during
the show's first season in 2017 she told
actors on actors naked stuff is always
difficult it's always kind of hard cuz
it's just uncomfortable for many many
many reasons as she told Entertainment
Weekly her life took a turn for the
incredibly awkward when she wound up
watching one of those nude scenes with
her family whoops I ended up sitting
down with them and being like let's
watch it and then instantly regretting
it my dad was like again Graham Norton
was clearly tickled by that anecdote did
you watch it with your parents yes
Clarke had no qualms about appearing
nude on stage in a production of
Breakfast at Tiffany's which premiered
at New York's Court Theatre in 2013
naturally a big name like Clarke drew
huge crowds including some exceedingly
creepy patrons who took photos of Clarke
during her nude scenes
unfortunately the show was slammed by
critics and closed after only 38
performances it's too bad our first
theatrical outing was tarnished by weird
audience members and bad reviews but at
least now she's got a Broadway credit to
her name and there will likely be many
more in the future after her breakout
role on Game of Thrones Clarke was
inundated with film offers with one big
franchise standing out from the pack
reportedly Clarke was offered the lead
role of Anastasia Steele in Fifty Shades
of Grey
the first in a trilogy of theoretically
sexy films based on the best-selling
series of trashy novels ultimately
Clarke
decided to turn down the role which
famously went to Dakota Johnson who
start alongside British actor Jamie
Dornan for the entirety of the series
and in 2015 interview with kiss-fm
Clarke played a little bit coy about the
decision that you turned down the Fifty
Shades of Grey boat oh well hey J Clarke
has explained why she made that decision
Fifty Shades could certainly have given
her more exposure as an actor but it
wasn't the kind of exposure she wanted
after her history of nude scenes on
stage and screen Clarke didn't want to
be labeled as any specific type of
performer she says she really doesn't
regret turning down the role considering
the bleak critical reception the trilogy
received it seems like she definitely
made the right choice ad Emilia Clarke's
name - the long illustrious list of
tattooed celebrities Clarke's first
tattoo was dedicated to her role in me
before you where she played a big
hearted caretaker who has a tattoo of a
bumblebee well guess what Clarke got
inked on her pinky finger naturally
Clarke needed to get a game of Thrones
tattoo - and guess what she went for
this time I was in a tattoo parlor the
other day trying to make an appointment
they said they were full because you're
coming in to get a tattoo of a dragon
yes maybe they aren't the biggest
dragons we've ever seen but they are
dragons Clarke was seemingly born to be
an actor considering that her father
worked in the theatre community in
London as a sound engineer the first
show Clarke ever saw as a child was
showboat she was enthralled falling in
love with the theatre right then and
there however her dad wasn't quite so
enthusiastic about her goals in fact he
took her to a real audition in the West
End in the hopes of scaring her away
from the profession she bombed
completely showing up unprepared with
just a folk song to her name as she
continued pursuing her dream Clarke said
her dad's only advice was to be aware of
the many pitfalls of the profession he
reminded her that actors rarely make a
living off their passion and even told
her that the only line she ever needed
to memorize was do you want fries with
that horse sure her dad had the best
intentions but fans around the world
must be glad Clarke kept at it she
eventually attended the prestigious
Drama Centre London
and the rest is history well more or
less after graduating Clark's acting
career got off to a rather quiet start
she had a few bit parts and commercials
and made appearances on British shows
like doctors and even a dreadful sci-fi
original movie called Triassic attack in
2010 screen international named her one
of the UK stars of tomorrow and they
were right on the money she scored her
audition for Game of Thrones shortly
after that career milestone but Clark
still had to make sure her bills were
paid at the time she landed the role
Clark was reportedly working six jobs
including a gig as a real estate agent
due to the importance of that particular
audition Clark called in sick to her
catering job that day
obviously her efforts were well worth it
that she booked the role of a lifetime
and quickly became one of the most
celebrated young actresses in the
industry take that catering job the fact
that Clark even got to audition for Game
of Thrones is rather extraordinary
considering the pilot had already been
shot by the time she got that fateful
call from her agent however the original
pilot was a dismal failure before you
think that's too harsh a description
it comes from series creators David
Benioff and DB Weiss who blamed unclear
storytelling melodramatic death scenes
and bad casting they eventually reshot
about 90% of the episode the creators
have politely declined to discuss why
they recast the role of Daenerys which
was originally played by actress Tamsin
merchants best known for roles like
Catherine Howard on the Tudors the
original pilot never saw the light of
day and now it's impossible to imagine
anyone but Clark playing Daenerys over
the course of seven seasons she's been
nominated for several Emmy Awards and
has made the role completely her own
she'll probably be referred to as the
mother of dragons for many more years to
come Emilia Clarke is the first to admit
that her Game of Thrones audition took
an odd turn
prior to her audition she'd spent hours
scouring Wikipedia to learn more about a
Song of Ice and Fire
George RR Martin's book series on which
Game of Thrones is based as she told
Jimmy Fallon showrunners Benioff and
Weiss asked Clarke about her other
talents after she'd read a few lines of
dialogue then they suggest that she'd do
a dance I don't I don't know how to do
it but I did the Funky Chicken
and I kind of moved him to the robot and
they said I heard I heard some laughter
going on
afterwards she evidently didn't feel
particularly hopeful about the audition
of course she was cast in the role
shortly afterwards Clark may have gotten
giggles out of the showrunners but they
still got a taste of the remarkable
intensity she uses to bring Daenerys to
life in fact it sounds like they were
completely sold on her right out of the
gate
our certitude was as religious as
Daenerys --is she was the one until
recently Emilia Clarke kept one period
of her life completely private and a
moving personal essay published in The
New Yorker in March 2019 she revealed
that she'd survived a very serious
health scare during a session with a
personal trainer Clark suffered a
debilitating brain aneurysm only a third
a patient survived what she endured
after a minimally invasive form of brain
surgery Clark learned that she had a
smaller aneurysm elsewhere in her brain
that could also pop shakey exhausted and
partially reliant on morphine
Clark bravely went back to work and
continued filming Game of Thrones
then in 2013 the second aneurysm burst
requiring a much more invasive surgery
an incredibly difficult road to recovery
lay ahead the second one there was a bit
of my brain actually died if a part of
your brain doesn't get blood to it for a
minute it will just no longer work in
her essay Clark writes that she's now
quote 100% recovered she also started a
charity called sameyou to help patients
suffering from strokes and other brain
injuries as a professional actress and
public figure Clark's brave decision to
speak out about the most difficult
period of her life speaks volumes about
her character
despite her personal successes 2016 was
a difficult year for the young star in
the aftermath of brexit an issue near
and dear to Clark's hearts as a Londoner
she lost a family member shortly after
the vote and both situations set her
adrift personally and professionally
Clark's father had suffered from cancer
four years and succumb to his illness in
July 2016
sadly she couldn't be there during his
final days while his health declined she
was filming a movie in Kentucky after
cutting the filming short she finally
arrived in London only to learn that he
had already passed away this was
absolutely devastating to Clark
especially since she was due back on the
Game of Thrones set in three
weeks she told Rolling Stone that the
experience only made her stronger since
her father's death she's praised the
nurses who cared for him bowing that
she'd always support England's medical
community from that day forward in 2018
she became an ambassador for London's
Royal College of Nursing joining the
school's ongoing campaign for financial
support from the British government and
the NHS when it cast is sworn to secrecy
while filming one of the world's hottest
shows and far-flung locations it's only
natural that they'd become close friends
Clark is no exception
Daenerys started off the series with a
wedding to Khal Drogo played by future
Aquaman star Jason Momoa the two became
fast friends while they were quartered
in Morocco together though Drogo is dead
by the end of the first season Momoa and
Clark have remained very close in fact
they refer to each other as quote the
moon of my life and my Sun and stars
to this day Momoa seems like one of
Clark's biggest supporters and fans are
always delighted by their reunions which
have taken place at major award shows
and Comic Con where Momoa made a
surprise appearance that did indeed
succeed in startling Clark
now as the show ends Clark will almost
certainly be closing out her character
storyline alongside Kit Harington he of
course plays the brooding Jon Snow the
presumed bastard who's actually Daenerys
Boyle nephew and her lover yep luckily
she and Harrington seem to be having a
great time together on set especially
when they're joking around about their
love scenes I mean I think kind of might
be the reaction
I like looking here and going oh my god
I'm sorry the pair have been friends
since the first season and each of them
is excited to finish the series with a
friend at their side as that heiress
Clark is no stranger to travelling
through foreign lands often on foot at
the beginning of Game of Thrones she
begins a long journey from the native
land of the Dothraki warrior clan
located across the Narrow Sea from
Westeros in order to finally take back
the iron throne at the Seven Kingdoms
she gets turned around several times
over ending up in slavers Bay and
subsequently taking control of several
slave cities before finally ending up in
Westeros in the seventh season thanks to
this storyline Clark herself has gotten
to travel to several exotic filming
locations over the years including
Croatia Ireland Iceland and Spain like
her character Clark became a world
traveler at a young age at just 16
she embarked on a backpacking trip
through northern India continuing into
Tibet having made the journey to scatter
the ashes of her grandmother who was
born in Delhi a few years later she made
a similar journey through Southeast Asia
as well as South Africa proving that
she's just as adventurous as her
signature character no surprise there
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
Game of Thrones are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]